what was your objection to it shoulr
when he said London is no longer English
people are reading into that that he
meant it's not white enough the bottom
line is this
I mean referring to UK cities or London
as non English is the key point here
Britishness is not determined by the
colour of our skills well he does go on
to clarify he said actually it's not
about racism
it's about culturalism and he said that
it's not as polite as it was humorous
it's not as friendly as it was those
sorts of things answers this is a man
who who left the UK because it's full of
foreigners and move to a foreign country
to become an immigrant please let's not
take him seriously mmm okay well that
particular point is a bit difficult to
defend I agree but I think in terms of
the the racism issue I don't see how
this has anything to do with race look
at the angle of football teams full of
black players no one would question the
Englishness right they're English it's
not about race what he's talking about I
think is that look at London 42% of
people who live in London are like me
foreign-born right so there's a very
significant immigrant population in
London obviously if you have half of a
city essentially that people who are
first-generation immigrants that is
going to make it less of the local
culture does the fact of life no the
fact of that is many absolutely right
but the facts of that is no the fact of
that isn't any absolutely right but then
he absolutely right but then he
absolutely right but that the city has
changed that's fine it's but just says
become less English it's ridiculous I
know it's nothing to do with race but
look at this look at it like this if 50%
of the people who lived in London was
Scottish mmm would we be okay to say
that it's less English than it was when
it was 10% we would say it another
question would it be okay or not would
it be okay I'm sorry head runner if it's
50% of the people who lived in London
was Scottish
yes would it be okay to say that London
has become less English well if they
were Scottish yeah right so what's the
difference
[Music]
do you not consider yourself as English
no why is that because I'm British I'm a
British so when you go to Scotland if
you go to Scotland so where Eve where
you come from what do you say why I'd
say I live in London I'm originally put
Russia but why can't you say like in
English it's cut because I'm not from
England I know I'm not I wasn't born
here I didn't grow up here I came here
when you're in Scotland and there's an
ax on the road was an arrow pointed
towards England do you not go that
direction because that's where you're
from England I wasn't born here I didn't
go are you from London no so he made
this first one and then lots and lots
and lots of people went against me and
then he said I suspect I should
apologise for my affection for the
Englishness of my upbringing but in some
ways in some ways I found it karma more
polite more humorous less tabloid and
less money oriented times and the one
that is replacing it if you people will
stay you know all the money
there's driven up prices in London that
means people can't live in London
anymore even if they want to it's
because as Russian money here there's
Arab money here that that's it's the
foreign investment in London he's
targeting the immigrants even with his
explanation he's targeting people he's
saying that you are not English
all of us have been here way longer than
for a specific culture he's talking
about people and that means it's go
racist connotations any but bigoted of
course it did I just think immigrants
are not polite that I think you'd
probably say it's about lots of
cosmopolitan cities in Britain and
across the world that's the only thing I
don't know why you know you're making my
point for me is we have lots of emirate
so he's not racist just a very naughty
boy
[Music]